[Music]  love is patient love is kind love is not  rude  it doesn't boast love also if it gets  wrong how do it's been hard isn't it let  go of a prayer for you you don't have it  okay just a sweet word you know it's  okay if you're not table is prepared for  you I'm trying to give you the tools to  succeed and this was not easy out there  everything I do is fear everything  I know you're under a lot of press right  now but I'm just getting really scared  you'll have this place to come  everything's gonna be okay right  we're in this together  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  you're able give me  try to hold this family together  [Music]  lord knows I've held on to way too much  hate in my life  all we have is love  all we have is now  [Music]  you  you